[Music]
how about how about a sexy video what do
you say i like a nice sexy video all
right me and my mom are on only fans
not every single photo i take it back
huh
wait i thought you said this was gonna
be sexy huh
by the way you you want to notice
something about the daughter
she's gross well that and
she's
she looks like one of robert de niro's
kids
yeah well that too
was as close as we are my mum introduced
me to the adult industry
oh god
oh god
oh this is
oh god
yeah this is not good
this ain't good boys
people pay for this
oh
you're right
yeah man sorry you gonna make it i'll
try
that's right kilroy's
pictures of us dancing glamour modelling
there was a lot of negative
but keep this in mind her mom brought
her into the adult industry as they said
commenting that my mum's forced me to do
it
it did get to me a little bit
and then your mom didn't force you to do
it your mom basically implanted that
memory in your head since you were very
young and then you thought it was your
idea
and i thought they're jealous because
i'm making money yeah that's what it is
frozen i'm gonna need some really good
palate cleansers i'm just letting you
know after this please
how about this sweetheart how about this
uh i make money you're [ __ ]
disgusting
hi i'm jessie jo
and i'm ashante
that's ashanti
that's not a shock where's cha rule
first of all
how dare you lady okay right how dare
you use ashanti's name how dare you use
the [ __ ] princess of great neck long
island how dare you
stand where she stood
yeah
we're like a unique mother and daughter
yeah no you're not you're not unique
you're actually a dime a dozen i slam
the muscles
huh
i've been in the industry about 14 years
she lovely
i'm very unhappy with this she was
struggling to get an interview or a job
and i thought why don't you do this and
some real money
some real money
we started a joint only fans and it's
doing very well
i can't imagine
yeah cause people are sick
[Music]
our only fans is about us
so you've got pictures of us doing
tip-top dancing naked
glamour modelling you go from having not
much money to earning thousands
is it worth it
yeah i mean there's other ways to and i
love that she says thousands like
thousands that's a good point that's not
a lot not an inconsiderable amount of
money
in a month we might did they have to
split bite with two people by the way
yeah take the lot of money and i mean a
lot of money
you just need to join our only fans
that's when you realize how much we're
earning off one person
once you book us and once you've paid us
you have to come back for more
you're not so cute
i was single parent bring
this is sick dude
you know what they're doing here this is
sick
oh you're not so cute
i was single parent
no [ __ ] well yeah i mean
no no [ __ ] [ __ ]
bringing it to you
if only there had been some kind of
warning sign or indicators to warn you
that that is how this would have ended i
don't think they're a single parent i
think the dad's gonna come back with
those cigarettes any time now
interesting probably newports so much
so my daughter obviously she's quite
protective and we're really close and we
don't i would say and uh this is just my
opinion here that you guys are a little
too close
yeah that may be that you have uh very
unhealthy boundaries
from each other
she's my backbone and my best friend so
[Music]
north london trash
i love that we have uk listeners ago
yeah that's north london trash
[Laughter]
portal 100
whatever she does
on there
and i love it to bits
oh they look like a lady there she's not
a lady now not really no you're a hooker
you know
just having a look on facebook and the
negative and different comments the
karina is a nice a nice negative who
even encourages their own daughter to do
such a thing
that person is right a piece of [ __ ]
it's just twisted and sick it is by the
way a piece of [ __ ] who also wasn't
making money on her own yes that thank
you i needed it i needed a hook they
needed an angle
let's be honest like
she's you're the hooker that somebody
sees and you're like can you get another
one and they're like i could get enough
another younger girl yeah i could get
another now younger one
yes you're [ __ ] right oh my god i
didn't even think about that so this
whole thing is just it's sick and evil
on so many [ __ ] levels man and you
know who sent me this video
it was pessy and he wrote hot when he
sent it unironically he says i'm jerking
off to this right now you guys will like
it
highly doubt he's yeah he did he goes
this is [ __ ] hawaii
no pessi well enough to know i'm pretty
sure that's not what he said pessy was
like hey sexy pessy in the house check
this out
yes i can why you [ __ ] lie about me
i knew he was gonna show up
i had your back bro
i know
not nice no what you don't think this is
sexy [ __ ]
i'm trying to eat a burrito and watch
your show and now i can't finish the
burrito what is it what is it
what's in the what's in the burrito
[ __ ] cheetos and jolly ranchers you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah you [ __ ]
child
you [ __ ] baby
oh guys i was sitting here trying to eat
my cheetos and eminem
you know
and now i can't finish it now i'm sick
oh he can't finish it because he's too
cause he keeps getting a boner
you keep getting hard on [ __ ]
i keep making these elaborate burritos
and then they're not kosher so i can't
even dig in
[Laughter]
plus you guys don't know but joy pesky
lives like a child like pee wee herman
so he has to actually set up this giant
convoluted rube goldberg device every
time to make him a burrito it takes
hours now i gotta set the string again
to put the candle under i gotta [ __ ]
reset the whole thing
[Laughter]
by the way the best part of peewee's big
adventure is the fact that that machine
does all that work and then he takes two
bites of cereal with a fork and leaves
mr d bob money's like he ran to the
computer to defend himself i will not be
beast merch as soon as royce started
really hammering that nail i was like
pass he'll be here within five minutes
oh [ __ ]
oh no but that's right that's fine pesky
you you have your kinks i know in canada
you know you guys like what you like and
it's we don't judge you
here i hate you
[Laughter]
why are you finding this stuff pesky
yeah this is really weird that you found
this and sent it to me with an erection
you're so [ __ ] much he actually the
title of the email was like i thought
you boys wanted to play and then this
video was attached to it and he's also a
member of the only fans
he play he pays 37 loonies is that what
you guys call your money a month
is is that what it's called loonies oh
no no no no it's it's a 15 toonies 15
toonies for this that's not bad that's a
good price
i love that the article is me and me
[Laughter]
some mothers are just not meant to be
[Music]
nicer
she's basically pimping out her own
daughter what she is
but that's exactly what she's doing
i love that they're reading and like can
you believe they're saying the thing
that's actually happening
can you believe it that they're being
accurate in their portrayal of what's
happening here
this is so creepy man their daughter to
work as a stripper for one i'm not a
stripper
um well yeah you are no that you know if
you were a stripper i'd actually respect
you
for two she's definitely not pimping me
out
i think we need to plan a shoot today
what are you wearing it did get to me a
little bit
and then i thought
they're jealous because i'm making money
and they're sitting that's what it is
what we have done to these people man
we're jealous like the entire generation
now is
basically
like the maury povich shut up you don't
know me yeah
yeah you know what it's bad barbie yeah
exactly
home being keyboard warriors oh i like
that we're not bad people we're just
making a living just gross yeah just
gross and i wouldn't say bad just but
yeah royce is right you're gross can i
can can can i tell you my autism caught
something
hey mike why is that frame on the bed
put down
why is that frame that's on the bed
purposely put down
what
is that about i don't know and now we
have to wonder what that frame is
what is that about what could that be a
picture of
jesus
[Laughter]
that's gonna bother me who is that you
know what's gonna bother you after that
the porcelain dildo that she has behind
it
also i'm glad that she's a woman that
has many scents that she wears
well of course get a different sense
you gotta buy you know if you want to be
a woman that people want to be with you
have to spray yourself with cheap [ __ ]
from plastic bottles that you buy at
[ __ ] ross
somebody says it's probably a photo of a
dead grandma
or a dear old dad
very hard selling photos of ourselves
latex
it takes a lot of confidence to do this
type of no it doesn't it takes a lot of
drugs
yeah if anything it takes a stunning
lack of confidence because you think
that flashing your [ __ ] hole is the
only way you have any value
excuse me marsh
i need to correct you
flashing your [ __ ] hole with your mom
well yeah of course i mean you know
obviously you want to make sure that we
don't lose sight here of what this is
what's happening here
back
as long as you've got someone that's a
100 behind you like my mom
yeah i'm assuming it goes to one bank
account
and i'm assuming the banking counters
yeah
do anything
maybe we should go in the hot tub
what swimwear yeah i found mine
oh there's mine hey
you know what you know what i hope
there's swimwear is in the hot tub a
plugged in toaster
[Laughter]
there you go let's go swimming
this makes me upset yeah well
i'm you're welcome that i ended this
show sexy by the way i you know
thank you for that i hope you guys have
a really really good good weekend